okon
cher envie de
vous savez
je
ne pourrais même pas trouver les paroles
je ne peux pas vous dire bonjour ou
bonsoir
et c'est la pure vérité
chaque jour
passant pour certains comme le dernier
jour
je
pense
à nos citoyens qui défendent une autre
patrie
sans relâche qui défendent la liberté
je suis ravi ravi
d'avoir vu tout ça
déroulée devant mes yeux cet esprit
fédérateur
je suis ravi que nous avons réuni tous
les pays de l'union européenne mais je
ne savais pas à quel prix et c'est une
tragédie pour moi pour chaque ukrainien
pour notre fille ce lourd tribut
le prix de des milliers de personnes le
jour de la révolution
la guerre la guerre qui a duré qui dure
cinq jours cinq interminables jours
vous savez
je vous parler librement je ne lis pas
des textes parce que tous ces textes
écrits ce sont sont restées lettre
manche dans le passé nous vivons
maintenant dans une autre réalité cette
réalité est devenue une autre
quotidienne
j'estime
que nous
défendons aujourd'hui nos valeurs la
liberté
la volonté d'être égaux tous comment
vous l'êtes
non meilleur
citoyen les plus courageux
nous les perdons et je suis fier de ses
citoyens vous savez
que nous pourrons dire que nous
remporterons la victoire
je suis persuadé que nous gagnerons
je suis absolument persuadé de cela
on dit
que l'ukraine a fait son choix le choix
de l'adhésion à l'euro porsche et je
voudrais
que aujourd'hui
vont
nous
confirment y ait le choix de l'europe
d'accepter l'ukraine
nous avons effectivement des
interruptions de communication parce que
nous essuyons des frappes
ce matin fut une tragédie pour nom les
missiles de croisière ont frappé car ce
qui va
dans cette ville il y avait toujours
beaucoup de russes qui vivait seule
avait tort
on amitié avec d'autres
et pousse la ville de kiev était belle
et riche de la jeunesse
qui se
réunissait pour chartres festivités sur
la belle place de la liberté fait la
plus grande place en europe
et c'est
incroyable que
la belle
place de la liberté a été frappée
aujourd'hui par les missiles de
croisière c'est ça le prix de la liberté
nous nous battons pour une autre liberté
et croyez moi
indépendamment du fait le toutes nos
grandes villes
soit bloqué fin
personne ne nous retirera une autre
liberté croyez moi tout plat ça dans mon
tre pillent
mérite le nom de la place de la liberté
personne nous ne briserons nous sommes
forts nous sommes d'ukrainiens
vous savez que nous sommes animés par la
volonté que de l'avenir comme vous
donneront à nos enfants hier 16 ans en
champs ont été tuées et encore une fois
le président poutine a dit
qu'il s'agisse fait d'une simple
opération spéciale qui le battait
quelqu'un qui étaient mobilisés sur des
sites militaires mais quels sites
militaires les enfants ne sont pas
mobilisés sur ces sites militaires seize
enfants
chers
députés
notre pays est très mobilisé nous nous
battons pour nos droits pour notre
liberté pour notre vie et maintenant
nous nous battons pour notre survie et
ceci est notre motivation la
plus importante mais maintenant nous
nous battons pour devenir un membre à
part entière ou de l'europe
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui
nous montrons au monde entier que nous
sommes
méritant avec nous l'union européenne
sera renforcée sans nous l'union
européenne
sera nous plus faible mais
nous sommes égaux initium comme vous
prouvez nous que vous êtes à nos côtés
trouvé non vu que
nous étions
réellement les européens est ainsi la
vie encore te rassure la mort gloire à
l'ukraine